wow kamala really kicked pence's butt
sorry just reading what the media has
already written about tonight
now what should you expect well two
different visions one positive one
apocalyptic
you can guess who's who pence can point
to an economy bouncing back from a
nosedive that was necessary
to flatten a curve and save lives
current unemployment has dropped to 7.8
percent matching 2012
obama the dems will lie saying that
number is still trump's fault
but imagine if there'd been no shutdown
the immediate call everyone murderers
oh wait these armchair doomers are
already doing that
she'll bring up the 200 000 dead hoping
you don't remember that was forecasted
if we did everything right
and 2 million dead if we only chased
impeachment meanwhile when she's not
pointing out how bad the state of
america is
harris will try to socialist distance
herself
good luck she co-sponsored bernie's
medicare for all bill
which would have banned private
insurance and put 2 million americans
out of work
she backed a green new deal a financial
monstrosity so bad that
joe hides from it like it's kovid and
let's not forget that kamala pushed
indiscriminate bail of criminals
when we dearly needed law and order she
chose thugs
if pence doesn't list a few of the freed
fiends he deserves to lose
but look this isn't about who will be vp
but who will be
p right cam a harris
administration together with joe biden
as the president of the united states
there you go now many support biden
despite his flaws
because it's implied that she's really
in charge
pence's goal is to let america know who
you're getting
if joe wins the most liberal senator
there is
yeah she's a number two but really
number one
with policies that smell like number two
if you follow that
you should be president